tout le temps passé devant le très
craint de téléphones cellulaires
pourrait-il entraîner des effets
néfastes sur notre cerveau samuel
vaissière souffrent de dépendance mais
il se soigne je dois vous confesser que
j'ai décidé d'arrêter complètement sa
trogne c'était son téléphone cellulaire
je sentais que c'était trop que c'était
que je voulais passer à autre chose
nous sommes nombreux à être accro à la
moindre vibration de notre appareil on
se précipite pour répondre à un texto ou
consultez nos réseaux sociaux samuel
vaissière et spécialiste en
neurosciences
ces recherches pourraient nous aider
décrocher
[Musique]
ce matin dans un laboratoire de
l'université mcgill
deux étudiantes ont accepté de servir de
cobaye une équipe de recherche pas
évaluer leur degré de dépendance
vis-à-vis de leur téléphone je l'utilisé
surtout pour échanger sur facebook
messenger qu'ils soient des applications
chinoise que oui chat à la fin mai
journée je me dis que j'ai perdu
beaucoup de temps avec mon téléphone
[Musique]
samuel vaissière compare nos téléphones
cellulaires des machines à sous ils
surent exceet dans notre cerveau le
circuit de la dopamine
cette molécule associé à la sensation de
plaisir le fait que l'on reçoive toute
la journée dès notification à chaque
fois qu'on ressent un buzz ou voit une
lumière rouge
on a cette espèce d'anticipation sauf
que la plupart du temps on est déçu la
plupart du temps c'est du spam c'est
d'autre chose
la récompense c'est quand un ami à pons
la mention j'aime sur notre dernier
selphy l'hypothèse qu'on ait mis l'un
d'eux laboratoire c'est que ce sont des
récompenses social auquel on est
vraiment dépendant et ça on comprend que
ce genre de récompense sociale c'est
peut-être même plus alléchant que le
chocolat que la drogue ou peut-être même
que le sexe et ça c'est vraiment
intéressant
en moyenne un à passe trois heures 37
minutes par jour sur son téléphone
bobby 3h48 au cours des deux prochaines
semaines
elles vont tenter de suivre 10 consignes
pour réduire leur temps d'utilisation
dans la lys désactiver les notifications
inutiles ou encore passer en mode noir
et blanc pour rendre l'écran moins
attrayant les participants répondent à
un questionnaire pour évaluer ces
éprouvent des symptômes de dépression
entre 2005 et 2010 est le taux de
dépression a augmenté de 50 2% chez les
adolescentes et de 63% chez les jeunes
adultes selon une étude américaine
cela correspond à la période où l' usage
des téléphones cellulaires a explosé ce
dispositif qui nous donne l'illusion de
connexion sociale ne fait pas la même
chose que de passer du temps face à face
[Musique]
des études ont suggéré un lien entre le
temps d'écran chez les jeunes et les
problèmes de santé mentale comme
l'anxiété et la dépression
mais d'autres ont contredit ces
résultats et n'ont trouvé aucune
association samuel vaissière aimerait
tirer les choses au clair at il dit
son étude cherche aussi à vérifier s'il
usage abusif du téléphone cellulaire
nuit à la concentration et à la mémoire
avec les appareils cellulaires qui sont
faites comme une secrétaire un
calendrier un agenda téléphonique
et puis aussi un gps auquel on peut sous
traiter notre raisonnement spatial
on ne fait plus rien ou total samuel
vestiaire a recruté 74 étudiants pour
son étude
[Musique]
vous de deux semaines ceux qui ont suivi
les recommandations ont réduit leur
temps d'utilisation de 52 minutes par
jour en moyenne 2 du nord le status and
body a fait beaucoup mieux
elle a réduit son utilisation de 3
heures 48 minutes à seulement 58 minutes
par jour
j'ai du mal au début à nettement j'avais
constamment de réflexe de prendre mon
téléphone pour vérifier mes messages
une fois que je me suis habitué j'ai
senti qu'un poids s'était retiré dans
les épaules une forme d'anxiété avait
disparu anna elle n'a pas réussi à
réduire son utilisation
elle est passée de 3 heures 37 minutes à
4 heures 39 minutes par jour dans
l'ensemble 23 % des participants qui ont
suivi les mesures ont dit se sentir plus
concentré après deux semaines 15% se
sentait en meilleure forme physique et
13 pour cent ont dit avoir de meilleures
interactions sociales
[Musique]
deux semaines après le début de l'étude
samuel baissière pousse son expérience
plus loin de ses yeux ni toile anna et
bobby échangent leur téléphone contre un
modèle non intelligent c'est précisément
ce type d'appareil que samuel vaissière
utilise depuis qu'il a mis son propre
téléphone intelligent au rancart ça
requiert un effort comme motive beaucoup
plus grand dans votre envoyé des
messages textes du coup ça nous pousse à
appeler les gens en personne puisse vous
allez voir en personne un peu plus
les deux étudiantes ont passé une
semaine avec leur téléphone à clapet
j'ai parlé à ma mère tous les jours je
ne fais jamais ça en temps normal j'ai
aussi lu trois romans pendant la semaine
des as n'a elle a détesté l'expérience
je me suis ennuyé
normalement je commande la nourriture
pour remporter avec mon téléphone
mais là je devais aller sur place au
restaurant sur mon téléphone je n'avais
rien à faire pendant qu'il prépare et
mon plat après peu de temps samuel
vestiaire a dû abandonner ce volet de
l'expérience le nombre d'étudiants prêts
à renoncer à leurs téléphones
intelligents étaient trop limités pour
mener une étude en bonne et due forme
il ne se fait pas d'illusions les
téléphones intelligents sont là pour
rester
d'ailleurs il refuse de les diaboliser
je pense qu'il faut être réaliste il
faut regarder le contexte dans lequel on
vit maintenant où nos vies amical
familiale professionnelle et amoureuse
dépendent en grande partie de la
possibilité d'être en communication
instantanée on a besoin de l'internet
il faudrait plutôt se poser la question
comment le faire avec modération
[Musique]